[Music]
rebecca is with us rebecca is in
indianapolis hi rebecca welcome to the
ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
so i'm up
cfo of a small business and i would like
to know how ramsey or other businesses
that you know
are determining what fair pay is now
considering the recent inflation
most businesses can't afford to just do
a sweeping eight percent payroll
increase across the board and even if
they can
it doesn't mean that that increase is
appropriate for all the roles but
employees and managers don't really want
to hear that so i'm just curious what
other people are doing
well to start with i would reset the
table
on the people that work for you
okay
uh people at ramsey hear me say
regularly uh your raise
is effective when you are
i i you know
we have never given an inflation raise
in the history of this company nor will
we
okay well you are paid for two based on
two things
in inside of our company uh you are paid
what the position pays in the
marketplace
and that's fair and that's right and
truthfully anybody that's got a job out
there you're paid what you can be
replaced for
with rare exceptions
no one pays you twice
what you can be replaced for
uh they pay you what you can be replaced
for that's cold hard facts i know it's
mean i know it's nasty but welcome to
adult land okay you get paid what you
can be replaced for number one number
two
part of what affects what you can be
replaced for is how good at what you are
what you do how excellent you are what
you do and that makes it harder to
replace you
and uh so excellence
and you know killing it and dragging it
home when you're adding value to an
organization they want to add value to
your paycheck and so we are adjusting
our comp around here and we've had some
pretty dramatic upward adjustments in
some categories
based on what that position pays
in the marketplace because the cost of
the cost to hire a project manager the
cost to hire a dev2
a dev3 developer that writes code a cost
to hire an administrative assistant has
gone up pretty dramatically in the last
24 months
more than any 24 month i remember in 30
years of doing business
okay
and ken you've seen this in the career
data so the first thing you need to do
is keep a comp study going and really
know what
each position
what you'd have to pay if you were going
to replace that person because the
marketplace is now if you are a dev2 you
can demand x
you know and if you're a you know if
you're a senior level uh software
engineer you know you're six figures
plus
maybe two hundred thousand plus
and uh so you know that that's that's
what you can get somewhere else and so
if i don't pay you that you're gonna
leave and go take that and so that's the
way the business is as you you do that
now but that doesn't mean we give
everybody eight percent raises because
the news says inflation was eight went
up eight percent you can't afford to do
that number one number two it's not fair
number three it doesn't make sense from
a business perspective
from a business perspective as the cfo
your job in hiring is to get a rate of
return on every dollar of payroll
and that's based on their productivity
not based on inflation
that's right and i want to add in really
quick rebecca listen
to help and by the way you need to
communicate this but the reality is
let's play this out they think that they
should get a bump for inflation so if we
play that reasoning out that means you
take it away as soon as inflation begins
to subside and they wouldn't be cool
with that either so this compensation is
never built on and should not be built
on inflationary pressures in the economy
it's about profit and loss and as dave
said value and it's the marketplace does
set the bar the marketplace does and so
i would tell you this is not a
compensation or inflation issue what you
have is a leadership issue and this is
hard
but you've got to communicate this
properly to your team and one of the
ways that you need to do this is i would
really engage with smart dollar ramsey
solutions uh there's nothing
comes close to what we offer the the
business marketplace in helping their
employees
get control of their finances like we do
with individuals on the show every day
we help business leaders help their team
get financial peace in the form of smart
dollar and it's one of the most sought
after benefits uh throughout the nation
and i've been on fox businesses with
maria bartoroma talking about this this
is one of the greatest benefits that
leaders can offer in a time like this
because here's what we know
everybody that works and i'm speaking as
an employee a team member of ramsey
solutions right now every one of us has
all the tools that we need to adjust our
lifestyle our budget to the inflationary
pressures it's called a budget it's
called financial peace and i think
that's what you need to invest in them
because this is going to not only help
them deal with the increased cost and
gas and groceries just using two buckets
that are real right now it's a real
stressor
but if we can help them manage their
day-to-day budget their monthly budget
and win in the now you're also setting
them up to win in the future they're
going to stay with you a long time so i
i think smart dollar and leading your
team
through how to handle their money in
times like this to where inflation yeah
it sucks but it's not rocking our world
well here again here's the thing we
share
profits with our team that's correct the
profit sharing program and so ramsey
family does not take all the money and
put it in our bank account when there's
profits we share it with the team the
systematic process that we used to do
that we did it since we're a little
bitty company
and so we believe in sharing
but we've never paid someone based on
what it cost a gal what a gallon of gas
cost
uh you don't want to be paid on that no
because at one minute it's five dollars
another time it's two dollars yeah and
you want me to cut your pay it's a
roller coaster right in half let me cut
your payment that makes no sense well
you know we're using the gas pump index
to set your pay this month that'd be
popular yeah right and so now
so we don't pay based on what the costs
are at the grocery store
uh but here's the weird thing
okay
all of these inflationary things have
driven up
wages that is almost every category
that's right and oh guess what that adds
to inflation because almost every good
or service you buy has built into the
cost of it payroll yeah and so you buy a
loaf of bread it's not just the cost of
the wheat that's right or the plastic
around it it's the cost of the guy who
baked it the guy who delivered it the
gas prices that delivered it the guy who
said gal who said it on the shelf
whoever it was right so labor labor
labor labor labor fuel
oh there's some wheat in there and
there's your bread right
and so uh all the increa you know labor
went from ten dollars an hour to twenty
dollars an hour all of a sudden and
guess what that shows up in your loaf of
bread yes
and so but also that means that the guy
buying the loaf of bread went from ten
dollars to twenty dollars an hour
because that's what it takes to get to
hire somebody in entry-level positions
these days so i don't have any of those
positions but all of our positions just
about every category we have our comp
studies we've seen tremendous increases
not based on inflation but based on what
it takes to hire someone into that
position
and then that becomes an element of
inflation
with trickle-down economics for those of
you that don't know what that means this
is the ramsey show